[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS HADFIELD:
Suddenly, I realize
we are leaking liquid ammonia.
And that's where you start
thinking, am I ready for it.
CONDOLEEZZA RICE: September 11.
I said, Mr. President, it was
reaching a point of no return.
So we show up at a Chase
Manhattan Bank with hostages.
And whether those three
people lived or died--
[GUNFIRE]
--Was on me.
CHRIS HADFIELD: As a
spaceship commander,
the real question always is,
what are you going to do next?
We see somebody come to the
door and he can't get out.
CHRIS HADFIELD: We have to
do a Hail Mary spacewalk.
It's just the ultimate test.
CONDOLEEZZA RICE:
You really don't
know at that point
what to believe,
and you still have
to make decisions.